It's really fun to look at these old
pictures once you kind of know what they
mean.
You know,
the delayed.
At least that's what I've discovered is
that once I kind of understand the
underlying rationale for.
I mean someone worked hard on that.
That's an engraving,
right?
They took a long time making that
picture there are serious about it.
And when you understand what it means,
you know,
all those people there,
their prostate,
prostrate at the,
um,
at the,
at the revelation of the law.
It's like,
well,
no wonder it's like breaks the law and
see what happens.
Break the universal moral law man and
You know,
I see people in that situation will,
as you all do all the time,
perhaps me more than you because I'm a
clinical psychologist,
you know,
and if the people I'm seeing having
broken the universal law than you can
bloody well be sure that people around
them have.
It's no joke,
like you make a mistake and things will
go seriously wrong for you.
And so it's no wonder that you'd be
terrified at the revelation of the
structure that governs our big.
One of the things that's so remarkable
about the old testament,
this is another thing,
nature commented door.
He was a real admirer of the Old
Testament,
not so much of the New Testament.
He thought it was a sin for Europe to
have glued the new testament onto the
old testament because he thought the old
testament was a really accurate
representation of the phenomenology of
Ba.
It's like stay awake,
speak property,
be honest or watch the hell out because
things will come your way that you just
do not want to see at all.
And it might not just be you,
it might be everyone you know and
everything about your culture that is
demolished for,
for generation after generation.
It's like stay awake and be careful.
And I like.
I think that people only don't believe
that when they're being hubris stick.
And I think that most people know that
deep in their hearts,
you know,
when you get high on your horse,
that happens fairly often.
If you have any sense,
you think,
Geez,
I better be careful and tap myself down
a fair bit because if I get too puffed
up,
man,
something's going to come along and take
me out at the knees and everyone knows
that pride comes before a fall.
It's like if you have any.
That's why it says in the Old Testament
that fear of God is the beginning of
wisdom.
It's like I've never in all my years as
a clinical psychologist and this is
something that really does terrify me.
I as I have never seen anyone ever get
away with anything at all.
Even once you know,
there's that old idea that God has a
book,
you know,
and it keeps track of everything in
heaven.
It's like,
okay,
okay.
You know,
maybe it's not a book,
fine,
but that is a really useful thing to
think about because while I'd maybe you
disagree,
maybe you think people get away with
things all the time.
I tell you,
I've never seen it.
What I see instead is that thing
happens,
right?
They,
someone twists the fabric of reality and
they do it successfully because it
doesn't snap back at them that moment
and then like two years later something
unraveled and they get walloped and they
think,
oh my God,
that's so unfair.
And then we track it.
It's like,
well,
what happened before that?
This?
Well then what?
This,
and then what this,
and then what?
Oh,
oh,
this,
that's where it went wrong.
It's,
yeah,
because you can't twist the fabric of
reality without having it snapped back.
It doesn't work that way.
And why would it?
Because what are you going to do?
Twists the fabric of reality?
I don't think so.
I think it's bigger than you,
you know,
and I think that one of the things that
really tempts people is the idea that,
well,
I can get away with it.
It's like,
yeah,
you try,
you see how well that works.
So like,
you,
you get away with nothing and that is
the beginning of wisdom and it's
something that deeply terrifies me.
And you know,
ever since last September when I came to
a broader public attention,
one of the things I'd be terrified of
making a mistake because I certainly
know I'm more than capable of making a
mistake and thank God so far,
either I haven't made one or no one's
found out about it.
So,
but it's like,
you know,
we walk on a very thin and narrow edge
and we're very lucky when things aren't
degenerating into chaos around this or
rapidly moving too far,
too much order and it's not an easy
thing to stay on that line.
And you can tell when you stay,
you're on that line because the things
are deeply meaningful and engaging when
you're on that line.
But if you're not existentially
terrified about the consequences of
wavering off that,
then you are truly not awake.
So.
And that's what I see in this picture,
you know,
it's like look out man,
because there are rules and if you break
them,
God help you.
Thank you.